okay so Donald Trump and people around
him and right-wing media have been very
quick to say the Moller report fully
exonerates Donald Trump now
unfortunately we don't know what the
Moller report actually does because it's
not been released what we have the only
thing we have at this point
is Trump's Attorney General William bar
has summarized Robert Muller's summary
of the investigation where several
levels removed and the last level
William bars report is a very
politicized level as we talked about at
the top of the show so if in truth the
full report from Robert Muller and all
of that underlying evidence would
exonerate Donald Trump release it let's
get a look at it if bars summary of
moller summary exonerates trump and
molars summary also exonerates Trump
then the full investigations case file
must really exonerate Trump and yet
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
is already blocking a resolution to
release the full Robert Miller report we
didn't even have to wonder if Mitch
McConnell would do this because he
already has this wasn't even a binding
resolution this didn't even have a date
certain on it it was a non-binding
resolution to publish the full Moeller
report at some point in time and Mitch
McConnell has blocked it from even
coming to a vote in the Senate chamber
it passed the House unanimously okay for
twenty20 with some abstentions there
Trump said it wouldn't quote bother him
at all to have the report released
William Barr says he needs time to
decide if and what should be made public
but the resolution doesn't even say how
quickly it needs to happen they could
pass the resolution and Barr could still
get the time he claims to need he could
look it over and yet Mitch McConnell
still is not allowing the Senate to vote
on it
how was William bar by the way able to
decide in under 48 hours that Trump
shouldn't be charged with obstruction on
the basis of Muller's report but he
needs more time to decide whether the
report can even be released Mitch
McConnell says that there are some
security concerns with releasing the
report and he's right in a sense if we
see the full report we might realize
that William bar is working for Trump
here not for the American people and
that would actually be a pretty serious
security concern and it's becoming very
quickly clear Pat that Mitch McConnell
obviously doesn't want the full scope of
the investigation to be known the most
likely scenario here is that while on a
lot of these issues
Moeller genuinely felt as though he
didn't have what he needed to indict
that there is significant damaging
evidence against all sorts of people in
Donald Trump circles that's the obvious
reason why everybody would be behaving
in exactly the way that they are
behaving and the only question is will
we ever see that report I don't know the
answer to that well I certainly don't
buy the national security excuse coming
from Mitch McConnell but I would give a
word of caution here because we we know
McConnell to be a very clever politician
it's entirely possible that he knows
what's in the report and it doesn't tell
us too much more than when we got from
the William Bar summary and it's
potentially possible that what McConnell
is trying to do here is to get Democrats
to expend all of their political capital
on making sure that the full report gets
to released and once the report is
released if it doesn't tell us too much
more then Democrats don't look so good
so I would watch out for that well I
told you earlier already William Barr
summarized Moeller summary of the
investigation which deliberately
excludes by definition any issues were
damaging evidence was found but fell
short of the requirements for an
indictment but we already sort of know
that it doesn't actually exonerate Trump
because one of the 4 molar quotes that
Barr did include in his summary was that
molars investigation does not exonerate
Trump on the issue of obstruction and
you're absolutely right Pat that Mitch
McConnell plays all sorts of political
games and he plays them quite
successfully Mitch McConnell outside of
people who
politics is not particularly well-known
but he's been one of the most effective
and destructive political forces of the
last many years you might remember that
he successfully blocked Barack Obama's
Supreme Court nomination Merrick garland
long enough for a donald trump to be
elected and eventually choose a justice
for the supreme court he blocked
multiple attempts to end the government
shutdown recently he refused to sign on
to this bipartisan statement back in
2016 which would have condemned Russia
for interference in the 2016 election
and now he's preemptively trying to
block the release of the Moller report
ultimately we may have to go the route
of House subpoenas and reading the full
report on the House floor to get it into
the record which can then be published
it could get to that point I hope that
if it does get to it the house does do
that but you're absolutely right that in
the end we don't know what's in that
report if it truly exonerated Trump in
the way that he claims you wouldn't see
so much energy being put already into it
not being released but it would be
potentially damaging to Democrats if
when the full case file is released
there's no damaging evidence whatsoever
I find it extraordinarily difficult to
imagine that that's the case
clean up your remote control clutter
with control center by kaavo which
simplifies your home theater so you can
control everything that's connected to
your TV with one easy-to-use remote with
voice control plug in your streamer
sound system cable or satellite even
your game console as I recently did and
Control Center does it all no wasting
time fiddling with different remotes or
weeding through search results to get
the content that you want one universal
voice remote control does everything so
you can say what you want to watch let
Control Center handle the rest
let Control Center take your at-home
entertainment experience from stressful
to simple and enjoy what you want when
you want it with these I set it up with
my TV sound system and DVD player it has
simplified everything SHOP NOW
get 40% off control center with promo
code Pakman that's 59
ninety-five forty percent off the
regular pricing of $100 service plan
required first 45 days free Control
Center is available at CAA veoh.com and
at Best Buy
Control Center by Kaba one remote that
does it all